you actually wants to cut all the balls
okay I just want to clarify scientists I
was ready I was like okay what how we
gonna negotiate this hey one is a be
sharp from Abby's kitchen and I'm here
with a very special guest Sara Lynn from
the domestic geek hi everyone so we've
been chatting about making post-workout
snacks and let's be real you know some
of us don't always love to work out but
we love the snacking part it makes it
all worthwhile it really you head on
over to Sara Lynn's channel you can
check out my protein bars three ways so
delicious so delish so good and then
today on my channel what are we gonna be
making we're making three delicious
energy bites each and every one use the
same base ingredients but then I
flavored them all like dessert I love
that so we're making one that is
inspired by a lemon poppy seed muffin
which I love
we'll make a strawberry shortcake
version so good and finally we are going
to be making energy by I'm on board
you know dessert all day every day
forget the workout this just sounds so
awesome I cannot wait so let's do this
[Music]
all right so we're gonna start with
lemon poppy seed absolutely so if you've
ever had a lemon poppy seed muffin you
know they're super refreshing super tart
super tasty the great part about all of
these energy bites we're using the exact
same base ingredients so they start with
oats the fiber yes tons of great oats
and of course if you want to go
gluten-free that's great we are also
going to use some almond flour I'm a
huge fan of half a cup of almond flour
in here and then to that we are going to
add nut butter I like using almond
butter here because I find peanut butter
is a very strong peanut flavor good
that's totally true especially if you're
trying to like really showcase the lemon
and the poppy seed it would be a little
more overwhelming and for our final
ingredient we have got some honey now
you definitely have the option if you
want to keep these vegan you can go
ahead and use some agave or some maple
sear
but we're great then it is all about our
lemon now as we all know you get the
best lemon flavor I think from the zest
so definitely that's really where the
flavor is happening so we're going to
zest two lemons right into here and then
we'll use the juice of one lemon got it
so this is like the workout right here
like we don't need to go to the gym the
zesting of two lines it was like my
biceps are burning as we speak Abbi you
could go ahead and use some fancy citrus
pressed well those be real but I like to
kick it old-school
take an old scooter right into your hand
and then you just get rid of the seeds
afterward I totally agree okay and for
our final step of course because they're
lemon poppy seed
I need the poppy so we need to add some
poppy seeds all right so let's get this
bad boy going okay
now you could make these super smooth
you can keep them a little bit chunky I
always eat them like this you could just
grab a bite out of here once they have
come out of a food processor always a
good idea to remove the play yes safety
perks for and then with your very clean
kitchen hands treatments for this we do
this yeah let's do it you could do it
right out of the food processor live
here so supplies we are ten so fam shoot
here a mixing bowl this is the best way
actually to get everything out yeah
don't waste it and any of these little
bits that's chefs treat right it's
Jeff's privilege I always think that it
is critically important to label oh yes
right um so we're just basically gonna
take this mixture pack it together and
roll it into balls it's really as simple
as that each by it should be about one
inch okay because obviously the thing
about an energy base as you know they're
very calorie dense yes so a little can
go along yes I look how nice your is
right it is taller than mine as funny
because I'm like excess resin in my vein
no it's so funny because when I ever
drink every single time I make like
literally anything especially like
energy bytes or like my veins the first
ones to come out so dainty and by the
end they're like people monsters you
know I get a little overzealous on the
portion size how would you store
something like this if you were gonna be
using them to take
so I usually will store these in the
refrigerator for up to a week um but if
you want to make a big batch which is
always the most practical way to cook
something like this then I also
recommend just pop the minutes in the
freezer
oh just thought um before you want to
enjoy them that's a great I'm actually
pretty good frozen - yeah we've got a
nice combination of fiber and protein
and and of course carbohydrates we've
got you know some some maple syrup or
honey or some kind of sweetener in there
in this case you can kind of go both
ways and it really depends on your
workout but I would definitely say that
you want to have some carbohydrates
before you workout and you also want to
have a source of carbohydrates after
your workout so well these would
definitely give you a good shot of
energy if like you're doing like a hike
or going on a long bike ride or
something like that afterwards it's also
really important to refuel just because
you want to replenish those glycogen
stores and that protein is also going to
help to your muscles recover as well so
these are good all day long
free post in the day not working out for
bed honestly it's like a box nap yes
right we don't hit that three o'clock
sloth lungs are perfect and the greatest
part about them is they're so portable
shall we move on let's remember I'm
excited about the the strawberry let's
go who would it be
I know we're just really holding our
breath we'll do mm-hmm
we are working our way up yeah the
healthy humans can't watch
[Music]
okay so number two is strawberry
shortcake what is not to love about that
right yes so I need that right now so it
uses all the same base ingredients but
in this case we are going to be adding
in some dried strawberries really
important to use the chewy dried
strawberries not the freeze dried yeah
because you need some kind of like
binding factor exactly exactly and it's
gonna give you a way nicer texture and I
find those freeze-dried strawberries as
delicious as they are they totally do it
they totally dude
so we have our strawberries we're gonna
be using some vanilla protein powder and
then to amp up that but then the factor
even further so it tastes like cake yes
no extracts more cake flavor is good
thing oh wait all right
[Music]
you always have the option to fold these
and after if you want bigger chunks but
I like creating you know yeah a little
more consistency exactly exactly and
then we've got the vanilla protein
powder yes love that and then also a
splash of vanilla taking that vanilla
way over the top let's take it all the
way mmm and if you wanted to take this a
step further and add peanut butter
instead of almond butter I actually
discovered that an enzyme tasting like
PB&J so almost like a PB&J sandwich that
would work to lobby on two legs no
that's all right let's roll these bad
boys yes let so again nice and sticky I
like the texture of these and I think is
really just right so good amazing well
these look great I cannot wait and we're
gonna put these back in the fridge yeah
that where they're going mm-hmm I mean
you can store them in the fridge let
them set up yep and up those stay
together really really well
[Music]
Oh meal cookies raisins optional raisin
drops well okay when you buy an oatmeal
it needs raisins do you go raisin or do
you coach operations raisins ray so what
I love about these is you can go either
with it in this case we are using
classic traditional raisins them a
little unhealthy bias but if you wanted
to go ahead and add some chocolate chips
hey you're not judging I'm not the boss
of you yes it starts once again with our
oats you'll notice I am adding some of
my own skier into the food processor but
I'm actually gonna stir in the rest of
them later to go boom just it makes them
I like that yeah and you need to look
like a little Grenadier for to be
authentically like a raisin cookie
precisely and then we have our almond
flour going in once again all the very
same ingredients in our goods almond
butter thank you for being my scooper
okay and then our honey honey I get a
Naples syrup which family be really
really tasty of me that's true for our
cookie flavor we are going to be adding
some vanilla extract which first we love
and then we have some cinnamon you need
like that cinnamon I'm a sinner and
fiend so we're gonna pulse all of this
up and then we'll just fold in the rest
of our every guy's roll all right this
is looking awesome
that actually looks perfect yeah okay
let's roll him up rolling with the hose
on the bottom of that thing is making me
lapse little little boats and also the
rolling with my homie I know Reverend
reference Lulu 90s nineties kids right
gosh totally 90s kids are so great that
is like the best movie ever made in my
opinion it was
oh you're actually are you channeling
your inner form yeah yeah you totally
are this you are so yeah how is that
guys here do you know clueless if you
don't know if you don't you have to
watch it go and rent it on VHS like we
did is that even an option I realize yes
yes well we're dating or something okay
we've got some oats we've got some
raisins
nobody panic they could be chocolate
chips but you're right just close your
eyes and imagine like I said you're the
boss are you
you're a chewy cookie for a mature and
Chris I am a chewy cook I don't even
understand the concept of a Christmas me
neither
and these some people think that that is
so bizarre I don't even I never know
ever have a desire memory that is
crunchy or crisps you know it they would
be delicious you could put them on top
of some yogurts oh my god yeah well at
this point you really do have the option
if you wanted to you could pop all of
this crumbly goodness into the oven and
bake it it's normal
instead of making bites that's a great
idea
both are great options okay so again
into the fridge into the fridge your
mouth yeah it's as simple as that
no babe no babe no bake cookies flavored
energy bites that's the way should be
folks winning winning
[Music]
which one friend this is tough I don't
know I mean I'm gonna go raisin you're
oka pork because that tastes like cookie
yes I'm gonna go the oatmeal for a
pregnant woman I know heels right what
are you going for it I think I'm going
Lemon Poppyseed a little little bite
appears so delicious there's so much
happiness and one tiny little bite and
poop and I'm just gonna skip the gym
hang out with these guys all day how's
that Sam I feel like I'm getting
stronger all right hmm
yeah energized I'm just gaining some
good lean muscle here well guys I hope
you enjoyed these recipes I definitely
am enjoying them and also you're gonna
wanna head on over to Sarah Lewis
channel because I have an amazing recipe
for protein bars three ways that are so
yummy oh my gosh the chocolate cherry
almond have to be shows very paper I
know I know who doesn't love chocolate
right so definitely check that out and
while you're there of course check out
all of ceilings amazing recipes tell us
a little bit about your channel so I do
a lot of healthy cooking maybe I say a
balance let's say hey is wanting a
healthy - a little more decadent but
tons of great inspiration for quick and
easy recipes some great dinner ideas
meal prep smoothies there's lots over
there so much it is like a gold mine
folk so when you're over there be sure
to subscribe check out all of your
videos you can binge them that's what I
you went and you have these buzzin binge
that works I'm not gonna judge and of
course if you like this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up leave us a comment
below we want to know what kind of
flavor combinations you would love to
see rolled into a ball or a bite and of
course subscribe to the channel and I
will see you
on Abby's kitchen by
[Music]